like Janice
yourself and please do you are what you
do what you're all about
with your politics
that concern on the MEP the Southeast of
England and my products have
conservatives center-right conservative
real conservatism in the mode of
Thatcher and Reagan and in the European
Parliament I sit with the in E&F group
versus Europe of Nations and freedom is
what it says on the tin and that
comprises of people like Murray the pen
get builders strapped who is running
Austria and also the great material
Cellini the new king of Europe and so
you have recently as it recently are how
long viewing and criticizing Islam is
not just about you I think it's
relatively it's relatively recent it's
since the obviously the terrorist
attacks in the UK in particular Paris
and that you see that it's a particular
evil ideology keep our Western culture
identity and our freedoms how's that
working out for you don't notice them
you try to speak about Tommy Robinson in
the European Parliament and they may
pass oh they did they shot my right down
three times in the past month then I had
an urgent Human Rights question which
always happens on a Thursday human
rights day is Thursday in the European
Parliament so I cleared it with my group
and I cleared it with the president who
was overseeing the vice-president at
that particular time who is overseeing
the whole parliamentary procedures so
you start to before you start to vote
you raise your arm and you are asked to
speak and I said I had an urgent human
rights issue to talk about
he is a UK political prisoner and his
name is Tommy Robinson at that point my
mic was cut off
and the place erupted apart from our
groups all right I had a furious rail
we've actually thoughts who is the
leader of the British conservatives and
and actually shouldn't be the leader of
the Conservatives because he is no
British Conservative my mic was turned
off as I've said on numerous occasions
when I'm talking about South Africa or
am I talking about other human rights
issues only certain humans rights matter
in the parliament it certainly isn't the
likes of South Africa and Tommy Robinson
Douglas Murray in his book and the
strange death of you know PC is that
instead of going after the root cause or
kind of chasing after been making
examples of Tom Robinson and anyone who
dare speak out about Islam it's a
strange one I mean I don't know Douglas
I regret him over many years he writes
The Spectator and others and I always
find it quite difficult when somebody
like him who is sort of part of the MSM
establishment it's okay for him to
criticise Islam and write a book as he
did telling the truth and we always say
exactly the same thing on our side of
politics but he's book has now become a
best-seller he's touring the world you
go to London Charing Cross and other
stations and his book is not that for
review and but we're not allowed to do
that and I think it's because he's got
very many friends
yeah Telegraph Spectator etc where's the
rest of us are not giving our platform
now it's been shut down it's only their
friends that are allowed to speak about
it that's a very dangerous thing because
he speaks in quite an academic way
whereas we speak for the grassroots and
we speak in a more sort of daily mouth
edited version and I think that's very
dangerous that you're selecting the
people that can be a critic trying to
preserve our culture and identity
we heard though Henry Jackson know
having become a weapon in the UK
I mean prior to today dropping a bacon
sandwich would be a little inclusive but
now you have that man Kevin who died in
jail either use custodial sentence a
girl in Edinburgh got a year sentence
for finding you Tomas in comes in those
triplets foolish man who threw bacon a
more skilled court immediately via the
mosque was given overnight police
protection and this is an abuse of a
police budget they make those heartless
traps for cash yeah when you look at the
crime is that the
they're forcing them to live under
Sharia law forcing them to female
genital mutilation forced marriages
underage child say it screaming rape or
dreaming and raping gangs
I think it's tipped too far to the other
side in London and we got Mariano
carnage as I put them to so find a UK
phrase is more interested in shutting
down free speech on the Internet where
he's got eight to nine hundred police
officers in the met pay for by us that
are targeting us on Twitter oversee
defeat crimes it's gone too far the
other way and carry on like this being
politicized and people like may in
Parliament is targeting people like us
and we're quite a vast army NATO the
People's Army is growing again and
that's reflected in the polls people are
very very angry and people are very
angry that they don't have free speech
and that bacon has been weaponized it's
is ridiculous and also the bacon is is
sort of linked with being messy it's
ridiculous it's one of our national
dishes